[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my public discord server
now whether or not it was a good idea to
make a public discord server is not what
I'm here to talk about in fact when I
first decided to do this I was only
curious if I could actually break
discord altogether short answer is yes I
could and long answer is yes I did but
what came out of it actually surprised
me I divided the server up into various
rooms that you'd find in my house in
markiplier Manor which is the name of
the discord server now you've got the
Attic the study your brother's room your
sister's room the bathroom the basement
the backyard the jacuzzi you've got a
whole bunch of different rooms and each
of these rooms have been subdivided into
a wonderful culture of people that are
weird and wonderful and awful and great
but I'm not here to talk about the
community No
I realized that there was one thing very
lacking in this entire server and that's
a place to relieve some tension and know
oddly enough that's not in the bathroom
I'm talking about a place where you can
vent your frustrations to the open air
and everyone and anyone can participate
at any time and very most likely all at
once this is my screaming room so here's
the thing in discord you can make a
public voice Channel I've got various
ones here that people can talk to
they've got limits on the number of
users that can be him I've got a team of
moderators that are helping keeping it
all sane but what I wanted is to make a
room that was entirely dedicated just to
venting frustration in whatever manner
you saw fit and so that is all the
introduction that I'm gonna do because
right now I need to find out if it's
gonna work because honestly I don't even
know you'd think that I would tell my
moderators about this beforehand but I'm
not gonna do that and it's not because
I'm a douche welcome to the screaming
room in this place everyone can chat all
at the same time this is a place where
you can vent your frustrations so feel
free to do so you will not be punished
you will not be reprimanded feel free to
do whatever you want oh I'm just waiting
for someone to randomly scream
yeah pressed by your use of the
screaming room
blissful science these are the great
things that you can expect out of my
discord server it's available to the
public for the next six hours only in
fact it may be less right now depending
on how long it takes me to edit this
video but if you want to join up my
discord server there's a link down the
description it will only be open for a
few hours as of right now there's
already well over 9,000 people online
and I believe the server has a total
membership of 40 about 42,000 people
which is gonna go up anytime soon so if
you want to join the best discord server
on the entire internet click the link in
the description below you don't have
very long and it's crashing right now so
we'll see you there
alright guys thanks everybody so much
for watching and as always well actually
before I go to create a few in fact just
for you guys I'm actually gonna create a
few new text channels I'm gonna call I'm
gonna have thank you everybody so much
for watching hope to see you on the
discord server and it's probably gonna
break by the time you see this video so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye